You know,
the,
the right wing is really hard on the
Frankfurt school,
you know,
in the Frankfurt school where these
kinds of neo Marxist guys who combined
Marxism with Friday and Islam in the 19
forties and,
and they were avowed neo Marxists,
you know,
so it's not like I'm making an
accusation and they were kind of anti
system type people and,
and all of that.
But I think to lay what's happening at
the universities and in brought out in
the broader culture itself at the feet
of the Frankfurt school is insufficient.
I really think that it's primarily a
consequence of the French intellectuals
who,
and this is obviously an
oversimplification who emerged out of
Marxism in the early 19 seventies and
produce postmodernism.
Now the thing about the postmodernist
types is there nested inside Marxism.
They say that straight out.
I'm not inventing this reed Darragh
who's like the joker at the,
at the head of the postmodernist
movement.
And I mean joker because he,
he's,
he's an intellectual clown.
And that doesn't mean he's stupid
because he is not stupid.
Not at all.
These people are not stupid.
They know exactly what they're doing,
they know precisely what they're doing.
They're a hell of a lot more educated
about what they're doing.
Then you are less.
You happen to be one of them and they
mean exactly what they say,
just like people always do when they
tell you what they're going to do or
they write it down and they say straight
out on their websites,
say that women's studies websites,
we think the patriarchy is an oppressive
structure that should be broken down to
its core and they mean core conceptions.
It's not just social,
it's linguistic,
philosophical and attitudinal.
It should be broken down,
was wiped out and restructured from the
bottom up and they mean that.
So when it's not accidental.
Any of this,
and I know it sounds like a bloody
paranoid conspiracy theory,
but you know,
I've.
I've always been of the idea,
especially from reading young ideas.
People don't have ideas.
Ideas have people,
and these are powerful ideas.
There's a good book called explaining
postmodernism that I might recommend by
a guy named named Steven RC Hicks and
his first chapter,
which isn't very long as a good
introduction to political correctness,
but so well.
So why do I think this is about,
about that?
Well,
her.
Here's my reasons.
I mean,
it doesn't seem to be about me.
I think all I did actually was actually.
I made the general specific k,
which is kind of what you have to do if
you really want to make a point,
a point,
right?
That's one place.
If you want to make a point,
and my point was I'm not saying made up
words generated by postmodern Neil
Marxists because I despise everything
they stand for and so I'm not using
those damn words and that's that.